hey guys I'm Ryan right I'm Dan cyber
we're gonna check out the trailer for a
game franchise I'm wildly familiar with
I I know plenty about games in all
aspects of gaming I mean that seriously
there's no sarcasm there Tom Clancy's
Ghost Recon wildlands reveal trailer
we're gonna check this out to one of my
favorite franchises of all time I played
the first game and I loved the hell out
of it
oh the first game with the the gameplay
was so good
Don't Tell how talking the graphics were
good yep on the ps2 I know the PST
you're not to say it to me like I don't
know and no it's on the piece on the
PlayStation second edition I know what
that is if it was expose that it's lie
it's the the first black one yep mm-hmm
maybe 18
oh yeah Peggy six gold bruh boo
most of us fear death let for this end a
blanket drug cartel death is a saint
they embrace her praise her worshiper
they kill thousands no repercussions
trafficking poison across South America
corroding governments how do you fight
an enemy that doesn't fear death maybe
you put them from the clouds
pre-alpha game Longreach the loan of the
cocaine if you take the cocaine for them
set eyes on white hat
will you fight no shadows the tag will
at least expect victim apart leave no
evidence behind
buzz please so [ __ ] cool she's the
creators of this game we're going to get
murdered this [ __ ] in an update Jon
Martell
no evidence
or you can unleash chaos strike from
every side confuse them destroy
everything
ouch to decide who lives
Oh
Wow
Stabler [ __ ] sweet man
damn right yours the snitch
why does a dead man walk
[ __ ] terrorist
Oh
you
and incited enemy doesn't fear death
a manipulator to me inside
until the monsters like and turn around
you
yeah mafia bad hey look Renee
yeah [ __ ] up the card set
with the next target
holy [ __ ] this was such a good [ __ ]
year for games when that game comes out
I am there that looks like a really fun
open-world man going on missions and
[ __ ] and [ __ ] up the cartel something
I will never ever even if I have the
opportunity to like this cartel god it's
like walking on a [ __ ] King you're
speaking way too much I just I would
never touch a member of the cartel mag
[ __ ] why am i [ __ ] because you
mentioned it really hmm
this old games about killing them yeah
you don't see me talking about it I'm
talking about cake you're certainly
enjoying the footage I'm enjoying the
game of Americans murdering the card
Burke fourth of July this is the fourth
of July video that's what this video is
dude Edwin evil for summer it was a
hearty laughing yeah the game looks so
good it does look fantastic
it looks really fantastic I was a big
fan of the um the original games like
the first Ghost Recon the Xbox do you
think 360 um editions the game I kind of
fell out of it because it was just like
it didn't have the same feeling as the
previous ones before but like this one I
don't know there's just something about
it the idea that you can tackle the
mission how in like a bunch of different
ways yeah that's what makes the game so
is he each member the team has their own
life it looks like each moment team has
her own special right and you get to
choose which specialty you want to be
that's what's really neat I saw a
gameplay trailer for Tom Clancy's the
division oh yeah that's also it looks
good but if I had to choose between the
two I would go with this head for sure
that looks [ __ ] phantom vision looks
good but they like its stuff yeah it's
the best way to put it is like there's
some things coming out about the game
they're kinda like heads it's kind of
their last year around this time I was
excited for destiny like that's when I
was excited for that's what I was all
about this e3 I am excited for so many
goddamn games the destiny
make you happy destinies I love hate
relationship you understand I understand
I'd have bad rng yeah I have that with
his neighbor of mine Benji you black out
sometimes you find like a leftover
sandwich other times you find a piece
Boop
yeah that's a pretty bad Pinot orangey
he's six years old but that little
[ __ ] pisses me off sometimes also side
note some of the soldiers kind of looked
like the Scout from Team Fortress 2
that's just a small seriously the
creators of this game will get killed as
you don't [ __ ] with the cartel
no should Dwayne Johnson unless you're
into Rocky Johnson [ __ ] you'd subscribe
to the real Ray Jack right here you can
check out damned gaming channel but the
cyber channel you can follow so yeah
he's doing a thing about a thing about
Ygritte I covered Microsoft Sony and
Nintendo's conferences now that I've
seen trailers for these I'm going to
start handling all the developer
conferences next hopefully if I have
time any kvass on Facebook Instagram
Twitter and vine
Walter Lavelle rocks
hey you real rejects rebels I just
subscribe you guys because you are all
awesome yay you individuals or geniuses
of what you do you know what I would
consider myself a genius for when I
watch other people's content I watch it
with a genius oh yeah I do
Ryan Jerry Veronica Andy pretty sure it
means you what is they're doing is
they're never been an Andy there's never
been an Andy ah minute my Andy
you might be thinking Brandi but I don't
think you would go you you look like you
could be an Andy hmm no supporting of
you thank you I guess but Lauren and
everyone else who comes on the show you
guys Rock I would serve more individuals
like yourselves but not everyone can be
geniuses watching your reactions make
day just that much brighter keep on
doing what you're doing don't stop don't
let nobody derail from making great yeah
I made great twice a week with my
girlfriend if you read on you'll see
what he's going yes I said great great
entertainment
oh it's entertaining alright yeah and to
top it off if I can get a shout out I
always give her a shout out every time
thank you
if not still thank you smiley face
feeling excited Thank You Walter LaBelle
Ross you know his name's Walter he's a
shaved head
please black you know what that means
right Breaking Bad black Breaking Bad
alright that's gonna be the next one and
Walter you're gonna be the star of it
you'll have Chris Rock - oh come on
that's racist
yeah is it he was in the the bikers i'ma
stop [ __ ] teeth I do not win in this
scenario there I should just gotta know
how to make a rush